at the end of descendants three did you
think you've gotten your
happy-ever-after mouth being engaged to
king ven and taking down the barrier to
the isle is exciting but what about your
mom
[Music]
now that the villains can roam free and
have access to magic your mommy issues
aren't going to get any easier
Maleficent sure is going to be mad that
you kept her in lizard form all that
time are you ready for your showdown
just imagine the sparks that would fly
if Maleficent came back and he summons
for what would happen when she came
face-to-face with ladies again
keep watching to the end to discover
what Maleficent would do when it came to
a choice between evil and her daughter's
happiness we miss Maleficent in
descendants 2 & 3 of course we got a
glimpse of her in lizard form but we
wanted to see the human Maleficent in
evil action and we're sure this self
appointed ruler of villains would return
if only they would make a fourth
installment of the franchise the
question is how would she make her grand
entrance
given that mal and Ben were engaged in
d3 it would make total sense at the next
movie would open with their wedding a
Cason vks would stand in solidarity at
this momentous occasion Hades would walk
mal down the aisle but her mom wouldn't
have been invited however that wouldn't
stop the most wicked of them all from
turning up Maleficent would crash that
wedding she'd be back in human form and
ready to wreak havoc once more if she
managed to get her hands on her sector
again she could cause some serious
trouble
of course mal is officially good so she
would fight her mother to protect the
kingdom that she's now the queen of but
Maleficent would remind mal of her old
plans to rule together remember the
lyrics in their duet in the first film
mal and Maleficent sang evil like me in
the museum and Maleficent sang the words
this is not for us to ponder this was
preordained you and I shall rule
together freedom soon regained maybe now
would start questioning her loyalties we
also get a glimpse of mouthes past
during this performance she starts out
by telling now I was once like you my
child slightly insecure argued with my
mother too thought I was mature but I
put my heart aside and I
my head wouldn't it be fascinating if d4
gave us some of maleficents backstory
we'd love to learn about her childhood
and her relationship with her mother and
of course her relationship with ABS we
loved meeting mouse father in d3 but we
only got a negative information about
his relationship with mouths mother oh
no I left your mother is not the easiest
person to get along with d4 would have
to include all the juicy deets about
Maleficent in Hades love story how did
they get together what was the final
straw that made Hades leave we would be
shown all of this in flashback form it
would be so amazing to see younger
versions of Hades and Maleficent right
he's busy in that same scene in d3 where
Malkin French Hades he tries to claim
that they have something in common
hey T Maleficent no I don't hate my
mother
but now explains that she doesn't hate
her mother because at least she's stuck
around so this gives us more reason to
think that mal might be feeling guilty
about leaving her mother as a lizard for
so long would now become allies with her
LIF isn't again or would other
characters fill that role back when they
were in prisons on the isle
maleficents in the evil queen we're as
tight as any backstabbing baddies can be
so these two villains could team up
together again now that the barriers
down evey is deciding Lea good so she
would use her powers to try to stop her
mom and mouths mom from ruining their
new United land you're new here aren't
you I'm Audrey what about Audrey indeed
three odd returned as bad as they come
she even used Maleficent scepter so
Maleficent and the Evil Queen would try
to recruit Audrey to their side and
Audrey would recompense for all the
trouble she caused last time by acting
as a double agent she'd pretend to go
along with Maleficent's evil plans but
she'd be reporting back to easy and now
I can't believe I get to live with you
in your very own yeah we'd love to see
dizzy with a more prominent role in d4
so she could help Audrey as a fellow
double agent dizzy would also be old
enough for a love interest what about
Doug introducing her to one of his
cousin's then dizzy and Evie would
double date
although Audrey's dizzy and Evie would
play their part and trying to bring down
Maleficent in the end it would fall to
Mao and the big climax in the end of d4
would be a showdown between Mao and her
mom they would stand I to I and another
one of those staring contests but as she
stared into mouths eyes my lips tint
would see a whole lot of flashbacks of
Mao as a babies and she'd feel a rush of
motherly love
although Maleficent would remain bad she
would allow mal and her Kingdom to live
in peace we don't see Maleficent doing a
180 and picking good over evil but she
would pick Mel over her evil ambitions
and she'd be off stirring up trouble in
another land far far away so that's a
wrap on what would happen if Maleficent
returns and he's sentenced for how do
you think it would play out with
Maleficent and now make up cut
Maleficent in Hades ever get back
together let us know in the comments
descendants for now versus Maleficent be
sure to subscribe to the things for more
descendants videos thanks for watching
we'll see you next time
[Music]